ich würde dem generalsekretär zu rufen
dass die gesamte regierung die menschen
dort im stich gelassen hat und vor allem
diejenigen die für uns gearbeitet haben
ja wir haben unsere deutschen
staatsbürger sicherlich dort richtig
raus bekommen aber diejenigen die ihren
kopf hingehalten haben die für das
auswärtige amt für die bundeswehr für so
viele organisationen gearbeitet haben
die haben wir im stich gelassen und was
ich richtig satt habe ist das politische
klein-klein die debatte wer ist schuld
heiko maas oder ak kann ein am ende ist
es die gesamte regierung sind es union
und spd die dafür verantwortlich sind
dass jetzt am ende dort menschen sterben
können der kleber wir können keine
antwort das sind harte worte aber ich
glaube in einer situation und
herrenzimmer weiß dass ich selbst ja aus
der soldaten familie komme dass ich
mitglied im verteidigungsausschuss bin
in einer situation wo es auf einmal 20
jahre einsatz 160000 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten 59 gefallen wo
das jetzt die bilanz ist dass innerhalb
von wenigen tagen das land an die
taliban zurück fällt da muss politik in
der tat sehr sehr selbstkritisch und
auch deutlich mit einer situation
umgehen und das wird konsequenzen haben
für die politische debatte auch für die
frage zukünftiger mandate aber das haben
wir als spd bereits deutlich gemacht
jetzt aber geht es gerade darum menschen
rauszuholen und ich bin der bundeswehr
und den soldatinnen und soldaten dankbar
dass wir über 5000 menschen in den
letzten tagen da rausgeholt haben aber
natürlich hat dieser einsatz wir jetzt
gerade endet auch politische
konsequenzen
paul du bist weiter bei uns im vierer
split du kannst keinen ball weiter
sprechen
[Musik]
ja ich denke das ist richtig und es auch
wichtig dass die bundeswehr dort so
viele rausgeholt hat dennoch muss man ja
sagen das ganz ganz viele das höre ich
zumindest aus kabul wenn ich dort
berichte bekomme ich jeden tag
zuschriften verzweifelte zuschriften die
für die deutschen gearbeitet haben die
für die deutschen in einer
als als unternehmen sozusagen gearbeitet
haben also nicht direkt angestellt und
alle alle haben angst und es gibt ja
immer noch ein großes chaos wie man
jetzt dort aus flugfeld kommt das muss
ihnen doch auch weh tun als jemand der
mit der bundeswehr so viel zu tun hat
natürlich tut es weh und ich habe jetzt
vor wenigen minuten erst mit menschen
telefoniert aus meinem wahlkreis jetzt
auch versuchen afghanen rauszubekommen
aus kabul die dort sogar am flughafen
sind die gerade nicht durchkommen also
da gibt es ganz viel aktivität auch dass
wir menschen jetzt noch mit auf die
maschinen drauf kriegen wollen wir
müssen immer nur deutlich einordnen es
ist ein riesiges problem wie die
amerikaner den einsatz beendet haben das
ist ein problem wie die afghanische
regierung damit umgegangen ist und wir
werden uns aber auch nicht davor drücken
können eine debatte in deutschland zu
führen was schief gelaufen ist was
anders werden muss was jetzt auch
stilprägend dann für künftige einsätze
sein muss sie wissen wir haben
angekündigt als spd-fraktion wir wollen
die enquete-kommission andere fordern in
untersuchungsausschuss also das wird
thema in der nächsten legislatur sein
und das sage ich noch mal auch als
jemand der aus einem bundeswehrstandort
kommt wer ist einer soldaten familie
kommt der menschen kennt die in
afghanistan gefallen sind weil sie dort
für eine gute sache unterwegs waren das
sind wir den entschuldigt dass das
schonungslos und konsequent geklärt wird
was ist schiefgelaufen und das soll der
eigentlichen verletzten daraus gezogen
werden eine frage eine frage dazu eine
letzte vielleicht von mir wie erklären
sie den angehörigen dieser menschen die
da
bundeswehreinsatz gestorben sind warum
dieser einsatz sinnvoll gewesen ist ich
glaube das ist sehr sinnvoll war dass
wir uns nach nine eleven an die seite
der amerikaner gestellt haben ich glaube
auch dass es wichtig war dass al qaida
zerschlagen wurde es ist ja auch vieles
vernünftiges passiert in afghanistan ich
finde das sollten wir nicht kleinreden
das hat demokratische wahlen gegeben
pressefreiheit ja kaputt es gab viele
sachen die positiv sich entwickelt haben
aber ich bin weit davon weg geräumt aber
ich bin weit davon weg die andere in der
regierung das teilweise tun zu sagen
dieser einsatz ist gut gelaufen noch mal
es gab positive entwicklung aber gerade
in diesen tagen gerade in diesen tagen
sehen wir auch was alles schlecht läuft
was nicht geklärt war und da hätte ich
mir ein anderes zusammenwirken der
westlichen bündnispartner der
afghanischen regierung und der politik
insgesamt gewünscht weil dann hätten wir
das land verantwortungsvolle an die
afghanen zu rücken
[Musik]